quero agradecer o convite pra que estar
e partilhar convosco alguns dos aspectos
considerar mais relevantes
neca criação e no funcionamento desta
unidade curricular e tudo começou com um
convite inesperado mas muito honroso em
março de 2012 do professor francisco
santana diretora desta faculdade era que
o constituísse uma pequena equipa é é
pensarmos no lançamento de uma unidade
preclaro softwares que os des têm nada é
mais 1.100 alunos do 1º ano é é
selecionada no período entre calar todos
um todo a criação do perfil curricular
da faculdade que em abril de 5 semana
que antecede os condições
fiquei surpreendido com o convite porque
o software só tenha ideias vagas
julgo que todos temos vagamente é e
minha grande preocupação foi imaginar
qual o contágio mais adequado e mais
estimulante para apresentar esses
conteúdos alunos do 1º ano numa
faculdade de ciências e tecnologia era é
é abordar esta questão
lancei um convite vagamente terminado é
três colegas e quero homenagear o zé
carlos cover
o general fonseka eo nelson michel diz
martins que aceitaram é constituir uma
equipa de coordenação inicial comigo
para é ovar a cabo todas as tarefas do
lançamento desta unidade 34 início
tivemos que atribuir um nome da criança
achamos que competências transversais
que seria um nome é natural uma vez que
iria gostar ué apontar para todos os
cursos deve ser poupado depois olhamos
com atenção para as iniciais de
competências transversais e
que elas eram onze iniciais da ciência e
tecnologia e então deixou a criança com
nome completo competências transversais
precisa de tecnologia o que lhes
permitiu de algum modo no tocar alguns
conteúdos tornando específicos presta
fecundado
esta é uma unidade curricular da exótica
por muitos motivos sendo que um do
século piando não de um departamento de
mídia da direção da faculdade e no
entanto é não tá não tendo 200 próprios
conta com 200 dos vários departamentos
que espera poder relacionar esta unidade
potiguar sair naturalmente que obtenha
de formação
começámos por decidir que a carga
horária total desta unidade foi 4 é de
60 horas o que se traduz numa carga
horária de 10 horas de aulas práticas
por semana e duas horas de aulas
teóricas e práticas onde fazemos um
enquadramento das aprendizagens da
semana decidimos ainda que devíamos ter
a sexta feira livre não por nós 200 que
nos fartamos trabalhar mas sobretudo
pelos alunos e em particular pelos
alunos deslocados desta faculdade que
são cerca de um terço é e sendo que esta
unidade particular é vocacionada para os
alunos do 1º ano entendemos que os
álbuns na quinta-feira deviam iniciar um
fim de semana mais longo é
preferencialmente com as suas famílias
tivemos também câmeras e maneirismos
abordar uma temática temática
constituída ou por um assunto por um
conjunto de assuntos relacionados a este
imediatamente levantou a questão do que
assuntos abordados para definir os
assuntos
vamos acabam inquérito é antigos alunos
da faculdade com o apoio da associação
dos antigos alunos da faculdade de
ciência e tecnologia e egito os
diplomados pela faculdade e permitir a
mulher e usar um conjunto de
competências que podíamos a sua análise
é e e de algum modo está confiável é é
prioridade dos temas a abordar
contamos ainda com o apoio de algumas
pessoas especiais que criamos que
secaria entre eles agrediram um modo
muito particular o doutor edson fechada
a deputada é consultora na área de
recursos humanos que nos ajudou na
definição de conteúdos
duas das semanas mais importantes desta
unidade curricular mas que além disso
nos ajudou é coincidência de materiais e
adicionalmente é segura anos anualmente
é só o início de formação dos 100 anos
do modo muito dinâmico que ajuda a criar
um espírito de corpo nos docentes desta
unidade curricular
o contra almirante aposentado joão
simões com larga experiência de
liderança não saiu da nato
ajudou-nos a definir também alguns
conteúdos na área da liderança
as técnicas superiores da biblioteca
dona maria do rosário do earth e roxo
ajudaram nos a definir uma série de
conteúdos nas áreas de pesquisa
bibliográfica e análise de informação e
estabelecem conosco uma importante
parceria é com muito valorizados
finalmente tivemos a oportunidade de
ouvir os engenheiros santos carneiro e
nascimento ribeiro gestor chechênia que
no âmbito das férias que são para a
partilha do conhecimento
vieram visitar no saque a furada de
alguma forma solidária as nossas
escolhas nos conteúdos a abordar e de
algum modo e fizeram questão de imprimir
o seu enorme preço pela revolução que
estava em curso e ainda foi cuidado
o novo filme curricular e em particular
com a unidade potiguar de 67 na primeira
semana de 67 aborda o planejamento
curricular para a empregabilidade é o
momento em que dizemos aos jovens alunos
do primeiro ano que o nosso objetivo é
vemos pelas costas saírem com sucesso da
faculdade para o mercado de trabalho
explicamos o que isso só vai acontecer
se não é verdade desde o primeiro ano
forem o
utilizando todos os meios ao seu alcance
para tornar em seu currículo um
distintivo e mais um volante o que pode
ser feito numa vertente acadêmica mas
que pode e deve ser feito em várias
vertentes complementares na segunda
semana bordamos temáticas ligadas à
gestão do tempo ao trabalho em equipe ea
liderança
o cruzmaltino mesmo é muito dinâmica com
muitas atividades muito do duelo é piada
pelos estudantes é e e tentarmos que os
estudantes percebam que estes temas não
são só valorizados pelo mercado de
trabalho mas a 1 desde logo muito
importante para a própria vida acadêmica
é de serenidade é claramente pensada
para alunos de ciência e tecnologia é é
uma chaminé onde dedicamos nossa atenção
a utilização avançada de folhas de
cálculo e cruzou esta é o modo escolhido
porque os estudantes viagem modo muito
positivo é esta semana fizemos uma série
de aprendizagens com os estudantes
terminando abordando questões ligadas ao
visual da sequer para definição de
funções quer para a definição de mato
gross centro rotinas e com isso deixamos
a sugestão aos estudantes do que possam
eventualmente complementar sua formação
nas áreas da programação ou das bases de
dados
ao longo da sua passagem aqui pela
faculdade é temos também a oportunidade
de referir aos nossos estudantes que no
3º ano vão ter o programa de introdução
à investigação científica ou o programa
de introdução à prática profissional e
isso é um bom momento para estar em
alguma de suas aprendizagens na área é
da utilização avançada de folhas de
cálculo a quarta semana começa com um
pedido ao estudante espera é
é de terminar em um conjunto a
descobrirem um conjunto de referências
bibliográficas relevantes sobre
determinados temas e na área das
ciências e técnologia claro que não
estamos só preocupados com a pesquisa
bibliográfica própria medida estamos
preocupados a explicar aos jovens
estudantes do 1º ano clipe pesquisa
bibliográfica pode ser feita de modo
muito sofisticado nos tempos que correm
mas tão importante quanto descobrir na
frança quer seguir há que lutar pelo vsr
cada uma dessas diferenças o que é feita
é o que é feito na análise de informação
abordamos questões de ordem ética quer
em termos gerais quer naturalmente em
contraste o acadêmico e finalmente o
frio às preocupações de ordem de ontem
lógica que são questões que devias mais
relevantes no site das ordens
profissionais os temas que os alunos
começam é preparada na quarta semana
pesquisa bibliográfica e na origem da
informação vão ser desenvolvidos na
quinta semana quando é abordar as
diferentes formas de comunicação na área
da ciência e tecnologia desde as
apresentações orais a pequeno relatórios
a várias formas que moramos com os
estudantes sendo fipa e muitos deles é o
primeiro momento em que produzem um
póster de na área da ciência e
tecnologia
estamos tentanto é simples - e as
temáticas que abordamos com os nossos
alunos e para fazer a coordenação de 120
t viu se obrigado a criar um conjunto de
materiais para disponibilizar aos
estudantes e sobretudo e mais importante
do que isso um conjunto de materiais
para disponibilizar todos os 200
docentes são provenientes de diferentes
departamentos têm diferentes por lesões
e que consequentemente importava é dotar
de meios para assegurar uma discussão
pedagógica da alta qualidade da univille
desta unidade porém claro estamos temos
cinco comissões de revisão constitui
dadas por 200 e doutorados de diferentes
departamentos e comissões de revisão
cada uma delas de
os analistas dos materiais esperados
para cada uma das temáticas semanais e
isto terminou com um conjunto de
materiais de grande relevância para os
200 mais de 500 light para as suas aulas
e um conjunto de milhões com estratégias
adotar nas diferentes aulas os 200 nesta
unidade curricular em janeiro recebe um
grande saco que é o sapo ctt onde só
falta o seu portátil e uma gestão que o
traseiro
tudo o resto está preparado é infinidade
de fotocópias que precisam para
distribuir aos seus alunos estão
preparadas e portanto digamos que é uma
altura em que os docentes já estão a
aproximar-se da saúde
equipa inicial de 170 para além dos
quatro ganhadores contou com 32 docentes
doutorados do onze pt - tentos contou
com quatro monitores alunos finalistas
do 5º ano alunos brilhantes que deram um
contributo fantástico para assegurar uma
exposição pedagógica completamente
molhada e vamos acabar uma formação de
docentes ao longo de vários meses em
mais de 50 horas presenciais à qual se
juntaram alguns colegas que não estão
descolados espera selecionar a unidade
curricular não quiseram perder a
oportunidade de ir obter formação nessa
área há um aspecto muito 20 para o
funcionamento desta unidade curricular
que eu aqui quer realçar é cada turma
prática é uma turma transversal é um
pequeno microcosmos da faculdade e
alunos de muitos cursos
depois nós da coordenação de ctt
dividimos cada turma em grupos semanais
de quatro estudantes de cursos distintos
sendo que temos o cuidado que esteja
pelo menos na mina e pelo nem pelo menos
um menino presente em cada grupo e isso
originou uma dinâmica muito especial nas
aulas muita piada quer por alunos quer
por 200
fizemos uma utilização intensiva da
utilização da plataforma de ensino à
distância é mudou
quer na fase de formação dos docentes
querem fazer disso os campeões em cada
unidade por hectare é a avaliação de
conhecimentos e contínua é feito o
registo de presenças dos alunos
avaliação é feita entre as áreas
distintas que na prática se traduz em
mais de 40 momentos de avaliação
individuais ao longo das 60 horas aula
o feedback que temos é muito positivo
sentimo logo nas aulas em particular na
última aula teórica prática o estudante
observa em um esporte descolorido sendo
convidados a aceitar o seu veneno sua
simpatia é com comentários sobre a
unidade curricular e originam murais
muito simpáticos e muito objetivos do
nosso trabalho muito debate que são
também os resultados e os estudantes
opta em é neva aliás a um formal da
unidade curricular igual miami são muito
positivas as opiniões que exprimem que
era uma plataforma de ensino à distância
mundo quer no sistema de avaliação de
qualidade da faculdade e o feedback que
recebemos dos colegas docentes é
igualmente muito positivo em 2014
a organização de 170 civil é submeter um
projeto à fundação para a ciência e
tecnologia que vai obter financiamento o
que nos permite dar alguma forma juntar
stf tem um selo de qualidade da pesquisa
enviado à fundação para a ciência e
tecnologia e estou aproximar do final
tendo reservado para o final é partilha
de três segredos para o sucesso dos ctt
o primeiro do segmento e confesso que só
conseguiu chegar à região através de
comentários que rapidamente foram feitos
por vários colegas ao longo dos anos e é
organização eo planejamento na realidade
numa primeira fase a coibição city
center pureza essa organização é e esse
planejamento mas numa segunda fase esta
organização e planejamento envolve todos
os docentes da unidade preclaro
pretendem lançar um em maio junho
um ano estamos em contactos com a
ligação da faculdade era tabu feira o
corpo docente que vai lecionar a unidade
curricular a ingênuo fry do extinto a
partir de setembro de setembro e
dezembro estamos a trabalhar na
constituição de turmas ainda
constituição dos grupos semanais dos
alunos é é perfil de janeiro em janeiro
e fry não temos a catapulta de
informações da avaliação tarde a
procedimento por parte dos alunos é
partir de setembro outubro entramos em
modo de seleção dos monitores que está
enviando a revelar uma peça fundamental
para o enorme sucesso desta unidade por
recuado em setembro que está mesmo em
agosto contrariado mas às vezes vencer
começamos a fazer a revisão dos
materiais ea sua adaptação ao calendário
específico do próximo ano letivo e
finalmente ocorre a formação de docentes
numa articulação muito complicada de
gerir o onde eu nestes três últimos anos
pude contar com o apoio destes oito
colegas é quem quero é deixar uma
palavra de agradecimento
os volumes do processo são as pessoas
sendo que as pessoas mais importantes
desta faculdade são obviamente os
estudantes que escolhem neste caso os
estudantes do 1º ano é que escolhem
estar conosco e que consigo transportam
as suas enormes potencialidades
talvez seja por este motivo que tenho
vários colegas dos ctt que terminam é a
experiência que a unidade curricular
vindo dizer que sua turma é de certeza a
melhor forma possível
e isto acontece porque na verdade a
turma de cada um dos meus colegas é
potencialmente a melhor possível porque
porque é uma mostra transversal dos
alunos que entram nesta foi cobrado
último segredo e não é um grande segredo
são os 200 motivados que esperam os
alunos na faculdade de ciências e
tecnologia sendo que
em particular a incidência que não só
temos 200 motivados como temos um
conjunto de 200 muito empenhados é que
estou evocar a primeira da equipa
clécio nos ctt e ao fazê-lo cria estar
um cumprimento muito especial aos mais
de 70 dos anos que nestes três anos tem
partilhado conosco esta experiência é
fantástica
este é um caso para dizer que esta é uma
equipa não só esta df da fotografia mas
esta equipa de mais de 70 docentes que
literalmente veste a camisola e esta é a
chave para o sucesso cti e é isto que eu
tenho que partilhar com um muito
obrigado